So those are the participants.
Now, let's talk for a minute about the review meeting itself.
For a effective reviews, the review meeting should be itself, be structured.
This includes the following steps.
First off, introduce the participants to each other.
They might not previously know each other.
In particular, one effective strategy would be to
bring in a member of a different team.
who's, you know, has a similar level of expertise, but to, to put a different
set of eyes that may not be biased by the you know, common understanding.
Second, is a statement of objectives by the moderator.
This is a reminder that the purpose of the meeting is to raise concerns over
specific artifacts.
And not get diverted into problem-solving or, or other other issues.
Third is an evaluation of the preparedness to determine whether
the meeting can go forward.
This involves checking with the reviewers as to whether or not they had done
their preparation, and to collect their issues that they've already found.
And also to check whether the artifact itself is ready for review.
Next is the systematic review itself using some means of ensuring thoroughness,
and we'll look at some of those in a minute.
This is where the term walk-through is very important.
The actual going through the artifact in a very systematic step by
step fashion to make sure the whole thing is covered.
During this process it could be recording of results in
the form of the issues raised on the review form.
After the systematic review, but still inside the meeting, there should be
some kind of summarization, often led by the recorder of the issues raised,
including a determination of severities and priorities.
Finally a determination of who is responsible for looking into these issues.
In many cases it will be the author.
But it may be that in certain cases somebody else gets assigned to do that.
There should also be an agreement about how resolution will be verified.
With respect to is it the moderator's responsibility?
The author's?
Or is there going to be a view review